hey friends welcome back to the deep
dive snippet this clip is part of my
conversation on the podcast with
patricia bright and we're talking about
how people in their early 20s or early
in life at any stage to be honest uh can
start a side hustle and what are the
steps that that person should take to
try and make it in this kind of make
money on the internet side hustle
business entrepreneurship type sphere
let's say someone is listening to this
they're like you know mid early to may
20's they've got a job and they want to
do a business on the side
to make that 8 000 a month or whatever
to supplement their income
what would how how would you approach
that like do you have a method a system
process like so i mean i would
tell people to use the skills that they
currently have knowledge they currently
have tools that they currently have so
if you know something so say someone i
know
who's really good at excel well just
either help people build excel templates
or sell excel templates like this is
something you can already do that's
where i would start off and then looking
at scaling that um or pricing it higher
that's what i would tell most people to
do i wouldn't tell them to go and invest
in a product um and spend loads of on
inventory without testing a model first
because i think that's a really
expensive and actually hard to like make
happen but i'd just say use what you've
got like if you've got a spare room rent
that out why you would have a spare room
i don't know but something like that or
if you like animals why don't you start
pet sitting or something or dog walking
so loads of dog walkers make like a ton
of money because they like dog walk ten
ten dollars for like 50 pounds a day
they can make like 500 pounds a day is
that the right math yeah yeah there we
go right they can do that right and even
for instance i'm working with a cake
decorator and someone who does balloons
in decor and like you know i'm paying
her 500 pounds and it's it's something i
can't do but she's really good at it she
loves it um so there's ways that people
can make money from things that they
they are good at doing already yeah yeah
it's like that venn diagram of the the
things that you're good at the things
that you like and the things that there
is a market for exactly and i remember
when
you know my uh
and you know i i like to think of it as
my origin story when i was 18 years old
and got scammed out of my life savings
when buying a macbook off of gumtree um
and i was like right i need to make a
thousand pounds back because i saved up
for like years and years to get to that
point and i was like alright what's the
list of things i'm good at and the
things i like doing and on that list was
teaching on that list of was like making
websites and on that list was um i did
reasonably well in med school entrance
exams to gain i was like cool what if i
combine teaching with the med school
entrance exam so i teach people how to
get into med school and then i make a
website for it that markets it
nationally and that was the thing that
made my business successful uh
and
you know
i
just think a lot i think a lot of people
are like hey i'm gonna learn day trading
completely from scratch and then i'm
going to make a load of money because i
found some course that does it it's like
it's really hard
to
compete in a market where you are not
already good at the thing exactly so
step one is to get good at something and
if you're already good at something then
find a way to make money off the back of
that if you can exactly if not it's
you're fighting a losing battle or you
recognize that it's not going to be fast
so if you want to be a day trader you're
going to spend three years or two years
dedicated to learning it entirely fine
but you might be broke and lose loads of
money in during that period of time but
you can get good in like three years
right 10 000 hours and all that jazz so
if you're willing to put the work in to
get it good at something that's
lucrative
fine go ahead and do it but i think most
people have got abilities within
themselves now to do something yeah what
about the whole um people who who decide
they want to become a creator because it
makes money and they see people like you
and me being open about some of some of
our numbers they're like oh i want a
slice of that pie it's not scalable or
sustainable if you don't want to do it
so i
when i started there was no money in it
so when i there was i did it these
videos for three years without making a
penny i didn't know you could make any
money in it i was just doing it every
single weekend after exams after
interning
like
every saturday i would just come and
make videos because i loved doing it um
and it i didn't see it as a business at
all i do think if you wanted to come in
strategically i'm not mad at that like
if you're strategic and you're like i'm
gonna make money as a creator and this
and this and this and this is what i'm
gonna do fine execute your plan and see
what happens
yeah i think it's like uh it's the way
we teach this in our on our course is
sort of this there's kind of two
approaches to being being like a
youtuber for example
there's uh the archaeologist there's the
architect so an archaeologist is like
cool this looks good i'm gonna make a
video a few videos here and then okay
didn't really enjoy that let's find
another one make a few videos there and
eventually they'll stumble on something
that's like oh i enjoy this people are
getting it's getting views and life is
good and that seems to be how most
youtubers start off just still making
videos here and there until they stumble
on their niche
uh
and that's probably still what i'd
recommend for complete beginners who
don't know how to make videos because it
takes a while to get good actually
making videos but if you are a already
good at making videos or b you just want
to treat it like a business from day one
then approaching it more like an
architect
is potentially a strategy where you
analyze the market you build out your
plan and then
once you've got a clear idea of what
your plan is then you execute on it
right um and so there's been quite a few
channels that have decided to for
example create content in the finance
space where the cpms are ridiculous yeah
uh because they're like oh there's a
clear business here where you make
content about books you need about 50
times the amount of views to get the
same amount of money so like i don't
just make one finance video rather than
you worth of books videos yeah to get
the same amount of money and it becomes
like a business decision at that point
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day bye